alrighty in the spirit of respecting
your time we're going to get going here
even if we have a couple people coming
in on two wheels
good afternoon and welcome to our second
meeting of the interim study committee
on house bill 1229
examining school
meals programs
i am representative sue mullen i
represent the town of bedford and have
been given the duty of chairing this
committee
with us today are uh representative
steve woodcock representative arthur
ellison representative olive ford oliver
ford and representative ralph baum
uh i'm gonna
sort of just
jump right into what our task is today
last week we had the pleasure of hearing
from
some of our constituent groups
and it spurred a discussion that
generated more questions than answers
from the doe
so if i could invite melissa and kelly
to come forward and
identify yourselves we're going to jump
right in
and you guys can get on with your day
speaking of representative paul
that's what i always used to do with the
kids in my classroom muriel
oh
so last week
i shared with the department of
education the list of questions that we
generated during our last meeting
and they included things like questions
about the number of students who qualify
for free and reduced meals
poverty statistics by community and
school
whether or not any arpa funds were used
for the meals program charter school
participation
the actual cost to school districts
after
state or federal reimbursement
and
whether or not the department has a
position on the direct medicaid
certification program
what the third who the 30 school
districts are that don't provide
breakfast
and if you folks would be willing to
give us an
uh explanation of how the summer meals
program works then that would be greatly
appreciated as well
introduce yourselves for us and take it
away does it have to be right okay sorry
melissa white a division director for
learner support from the department of
ed
and kelly rambo administrator for
nutrition programs and services at the
department of education
okay so um
i'll start with um i have just taken all
of your questions and kind of put them
into a document for myself and then what
you have in the packet in front of you
is some of the detailed information and
data from along with those questions
so the first question that we had was
schools that do not have a breakfast
program so in your packet you'll find
a documentation that says breakfast
twenty
one twenty two
and
this
on the
right side you will see um zeros and
ones so it's sorted by that all of those
that are zero are those that do not
participate in the breakfast program for
this current year and all those that are
one um which would be the rest of the
document are those that participate
terrific thank you um and so the
organizational name is the sau and then
you can see each specific school is the
site name that goes along with that
and just so that you um understand this
it kind of goes along with the the
question um
that was
the i think leave the last question
and explain why new hampshire ranks
number 47 in the national school lunch
program so this document obviously shows
that we have a great deal of those that
are participating for 21 22 and that is
due to the free meals
so
normally
pre-covered
there has been a struggle for new
hampshire schools to be able to
serve a breakfast program
and and some of those struggles or
factors that might contribute to that
would be
staffing and that would be inclusive of
wages are they part-time are they
full-time if they're full-time then
obviously insurance comes with that
and
um
lunch is obviously the the bigger time
that you would need people in so
so that's also taking consideration
um equipment do you have the right
equipment to be able to run a breakfast
program
and that would be
are you serving in the hallway is it a
grab-and-go do you need kiosks so
there's all those things to think about
for for that program for breakfast
scheduling of the school day the school
day is obviously already the schedule is
already in place
and then that goes along with bus
schedules
is there enough time in the morning for
those students to get off the bus get in
and get a breakfast and so um all of
those things that
are to take into consideration are
actually at the local level that's not
something that the department of
education determines
kelly can i ask a question about the
list sure
does this list include public
public charter
and privates that are participating in
the food program
this list is everyone that we have at
the department of education that would
or were not participate in the program
terrific thank you
my follow-up question is i i can't help
but notice that the first three
non-breakfast participants are the three
elementary schools in bedford
i also know that the intermediate the
middle and high school do participate in
in the breakfast program how common is
that
um
it's
it could be more common um again with
staffing depending on where your your
staffing is at at the school could be
could be a factor like stated before
that if you serve more meals at the high
school than you would at the elementary
school then you have that staff in
um to be able to to serve that um the
time frame also in the morning might be
different for grab and go um you know at
the the middle school at the high school
they can handle a grab-and-go
situation whereas the elementary school
they might need a little bit more
guidance and also
the the staffing piece too is not only
the nutrition department staff but the
school staff needs someone in there to
be able to monitor if they're eating in
the cafeteria you need to have a monitor
in there too so there's a lot of factors
that go into
when thinking about you know running a
breakfast program
uh representative ellison thank you
madam chair thank you
uh if we were to back up this first
chart the breakfast 2021 to 22 like
three years
before we got into uh you know
eligibility everybody's eligible would
these would these look the same i mean
today
um i can get that information for you
for for our next meeting okay i can pull
the um the same report for
um let's say 19 that's that's kind of
our year that that we're we're looking
at
that would be great thank you
representative
woodcock thank you thank you madam chair
um kelly thank you for taking this
question there's a personal question in
terms of vested interest uh i don't see
either of the charter schools from the
conway area
uh in your listening
period so that mean they did not apply
or they were not eligible one of those
um they might not run a mail program
through our through our program at all
okay so there could be then more than 30
we just don't know who they are
that would be correct yes thank you
thank you manager
representative boehm
yeah i'm just a question on what are we
doing here
the purpose of this meeting was to see
if we approve an interim study for this
and look like we are doing what the
committee is supposed to be doing that
we are going to
say bring forth next year or not we're
doing the committee's work that we're
going to propose happen
so i think we're this is going way
overboard of what we're doing actually
um representative bohm if you go back to
the discussion of this interim study
that we had when we met as a full
committee i raised that issue to
chairman ladd and chairman ladd jokingly
said
that he was going to make me the chair
of the committee because he saw this as
a good opportunity for us to discuss
the the issue as it related to all of
the food bills
so um i i understand that and i made a
joke about it and and said uh you know
we're having a committee to decide
whether or not we're having a committee
and
he suggested that we do the work anyhow
yeah but the thing is it looks like no
the members of the committee were going
to recommend we have it anyway so
aren't we just pretty much wasting our
time we're going to bring this bill
forward next year anyway so to establish
the committee we are not establishing a
committee this is an interim study to
see if we should establish a committee
we're doing all that committee's work
here
thank you for your feedback
well
just clarification from the chair uh
that the
representative
is certainly
right in referencing one of the bills
that we have we have four others which
are deal with
various breakfast programs or various
feeding programs that it looks to me
like that's sort of what we're supposed
to study so it's that doesn't appear to
me that we're limited to one of the five
bills that that was
presented to us um we had a lengthy
discussion around the farm to school
bill
and when uh
we were
in
respectful debate over that farm to uh
school bill
that was the first opportunity that
representative ladd took
to
marrying all of the
food bills if you will
into
a collective discussion i believe he saw
it uh representative boehm as
being an efficient way of looking at the
topic
and sort of uh doing a lot of the
preliminary work ahead of next session
representative paul
thank you madam chair and
actually i can just comment on that
right okay um
yeah i signed up for this committee to
become informed
so i think becoming informed is not a
waste of time uh and and i would go
along with what you're saying that's all
the bills all food stuff let's get
informed and move forward
thank you
the good news representative baum is
that i have promised that these meetings
will be succinct to the point and that
we will not uh labor here into the wee
hours
well just just one point too i mean
we're doing all this work
not knowing who will even be here next
year to have to hear all this
information all all over again that's
one of my points
there's truth in that
okay kelly continue melissa wherever
whatever direction you're going in
please continue okay thank you
um so the next question we had was the
startup cost to run a breakfast um and
and that is determined at the local
level that's not something that we can
determine at the state level for that
and
to the other factors that i spoke about
um they're individualized to each sau
that would be staffing equipment
um schedule of the day bus schedules etc
so those are the things that that would
be determined for that so unfortunately
that's at a local level
the the number of students who qualify
for free and reduced meals
in your packet you're going to find
that we have printed out for you
some aggregate data for that
if you go behind the national school
lunch program one
these are
landscape and there should be data from
18 19
19 20
21 and 21 22.
and the reason for looking at those is
like i said before is our kind of our
target that is pre-coped that that we've
been using
and then
moving forward we we know that 1920 was
the start of covet and
2021 and 21-22
are when meals have been free for for
those so i just wanted you to have all
of that data to be able to compare to
and just to add to that
we did see about a 25 reduction in
families filling out the free and
reduced forms
compared to before the pandemic versus
after the pandemic when those meals
became free
for all
does anybody have any questions
for the department at this point
great continue okay
um thank you and so the nutrition
standards were another question that
were raised so also in your packets you
will see that
right behind those the national school
lunch meal program standards are in
there also the breakfast programs are
right behind that
then following that are the sodium
targets
and there is and i know this um
might be a little much and confusing to
to look at but i just wanted you to have
all the the information in front of you
the one behind that
is a
whether you run a three day four day or
five day program at your school and the
one
last one behind that is the
newest from the usda they're the
transitional standards
and those are going to be for milk whole
grains and the sodium final rule on that
can i ask you a question on that one
so did you
have you seen the bill from last session
on nutritional standards that was
talking about sodium levels and whole
grains and yes i mean it was estimated
that it was going to require six
additional staff members at the
department
to administer
the reduction of
sodium levels and
how how do the standards that are
currently in place
stack up next to what was being proposed
um
unfortunately for for both of us we were
not here during um that ta that was
given so um
if we could we could come back to the
answer for that question okay
it was uh house bill 1561.
just i just want to make sure i
understand it and answer appropriately
yeah yeah no i just want to make sure
that you know which bill i'm referencing
it was house bill 1561
there was an amendment to it
it
all of these bills were ultimately found
in expedient to legislate but i think
that you know a lot of the reason that
that these bills were scuttled was
because of the price tag that was
associated with it
so i'm just curious as to
the standards that they were proposing
how
what has happened in the interim how do
they stack up next to what you're
already doing
and you know would it actually cost 445
to lower sodium standards and
increase whole grains or whatever
there's a financial note on that bill so
when you look at it you'll see what they
estimated as the cost okay
thank you and we will get back to you on
that one perfect
uh representative woodcock thank you a
question on
my own notification uh on the one that
dealt with the the uh
calculations for the usda thank you
everyone thank you uh i i think you may
have explained this the other day when i
was not here so maybe that i apologize
for not being here um
the three four five three four six days
sequence i i don't understand that
it's very it's a confusing um
kind of confusing document so um there
might be schools that only operate three
days a week um and and keep in mind this
is a usda document so it's it's more for
the whole state of the united states so
can you just tell me which one you're
looking at yes so it is it looks like
this one it's a stapled page and it says
short term short and long lingual
calculations yeah okay
so here in new hampshire um we follow
the
this would be for um
let's say if you had a
residential or non-residential location
that you were serving for and the
students
would live there or stay there you would
operate six days a week or you'd operate
seven days a week so this is um kind of
the
unusual norm
um if you didn't run a five day a week
program i just wanted you to have this
this documentation okay and i apologize
well thank you so much for clarifying
that thank you manager
i find is there no five day schedule
so
the the normal five-day schedule is the
single page that is in front of you um
that is just and i i probably should
have
um left that out maybe lesson is more on
that um so the the five-day schedule are
the two single pages that you have and
that would be for lunch and then the
separate one for breakfast
representative ellison uh
not necessarily on this particular chart
is it okay to ask a question
let me just uh see if i can save these
guys from us
playing pac-man with the information
here um
does anybody have any questions about
the five-day schedule and the foods that
are being required offered
okay representative ellison you're on
thank you uh
sort of shifting over to once again the
participation rates
uh the food research and action center
lists new hampshire as 50th in terms of
participation when you look at the
number of students who are in
the
lunch program
versus or part of of the breakfast
program and they list us at 38 or 37
something like that
it's it's hard as you know to kind of
find comparable states
but i i pulled maine and vermont maine
is at 57 for months at 61 in terms of
participation rate
any thoughts on your part about why
there's this differential in terms of
more students being served breakfast who
are eligible in those two states than in
new hampshire
like i stated before for breakfast
there's a number of factors that that
could contribute to that i can't speak
directly because it is a local level
decision
unfortunately and
we have seen with the obviously in the
data you can see in front of you with
the availability of free meals there is
an increase in in that participation so
those are all things to take into
consideration on that
as far as the
the aggregate data that we have to
melissa's point previously we have seen
a decrease in um
families filling out the applications so
i know there is a
a big concern for that obviously next
year as the meals do
revert back to and and the waivers that
are currently in place
um expire on june 30th okay excuse me
follow up follow up um
then in in looking at this data once
again and i understand the explanation
uh
are you in a position
to be dealing with these other states
saying what are you doing we're not
doing because i assume
that this they deal with the same issues
around
fewer people filling out the
applications i assume they deal with
local school budgets and money i mean
what what do they do that we're not
doing i guess that's my question
i think that that would be you know
reasonable for us to reach out to to
gather more information from the other
states to see if there's chart you know
there's something specific if there's
funding that they provide to the schools
specifically for this purpose so yes we
can definitely research that with with
uh our neighboring states and then also
we'll look at um
other states that are
comparable to us like the dakotas
and montana we tend to look at them
because even though they're very large
states they tend to have a very small
population like we do i'd be great i'd
be very interested in whatever you would
could come up with great yeah in some of
the reading that i've done i i don't
think new hampshire is the only state
that has struggled with
outreach
you know i i i think this is probably a
golden opportunity time this transition
back into
sort of our new normal from the pandemic
into looking at you know what kinds of
things
are are other states doing if they are
or you know is new hampshire in a
position to be
sort of a trailblazer on how to get to
as many of those kids families as we can
because my
like you i my fear is that
because we've now had years of uh
free meals for everybody
that parents are going to be under the
assumption that they don't have to fill
out paperwork and then you find out that
you do have to fill out the paperwork
and by the time you fill the paperwork
out you've missed the deadlines and uh
you know there's all kinds of
complications out there so
i would uh
i would think that we would want to at
least
consider those
things thank you
how about arpa funds
has the school
lunch program uh
received arba funds utilized arpa funds
are you on the radar so the schools are
eligible to use their arpa funds for
this purpose it's considered an
allowable use of funds but
because the meals are free
and the funding is already there they're
choosing then to use the arpa funds for
other purposes as opposed to using it
for this particular program since it's
already
paid for yeah i was thinking more along
the lines of that public relations piece
of getting
applications into the hands of every
family that's eligible you know that
kind of thing
more so than paying for the meals
just a thought increasing the outreach
yeah i mean that is definitely
considered an allowable use of funds
they could use the funds for that
other questions
summer meals
um
so summer meals um just like the
the past two years have fallen into the
the um free or meals at no cost so this
year will be the first year that we're
reverting back to
what we call
and we have a lot of acronyms so bear
with me
so we have sfsp which is summer food
service program
we also have seamless summer option
which we
is sso which is currently what every
school is running now in new hampshire
for the free
free program that's just how the usda is
categorizing that
as far as funding is concerned for them
and we also have what's called extended
nutrition service lunch program so that
would be if a school doesn't qualify for
those other two programs they do still
have the opportunity to every every
school has an opportunity to run a meal
program however it would be an extension
of what they do during the school year
meaning that meals could be free reduced
paid
and applications would be needed for
eligibility whereas the other two um
there's aggregate data that usda uses to
to categorize those that might fall into
it for
um for their eligibility for that
representative woodcock thank you very
much uh on the ss
program yeah uh towns and cities that
use uh recreation departments and those
facilities that that's where that money
comes from that program
um
so those would
there
would be considered camps so summer is a
very complex um program when when it's
broken down
we have
sponsors that would sponsor a maybe a
program that couldn't um
that couldn't do it itself so we have a
great number of sponsors in new
hampshire that pick up um
the
let's say the administration for for
those programs and then um
so those would be those would fall under
that kind of um program so they might
have a sponsorship to be able to do that
okay thank you thank you
other questions
do you have any questions of us or would
you just like to continue
um
nope i think we're good all right um
so charter school participation
if you turn in your packet to
national school lunch program sites 2122
those are all of our current
sites that participate in the national
school lunch program
whether it be breakfast or lunch so it's
different than the breakfast one
kelly do you offhand know how many
charter schools are participating
um i believe it is
on the back last page
it's six public charter schools and
eight private schools
okay
and just a note also this is not the
total number of public schools that's
obviously individual schools and not
saus that's why it's
that number
without looking at this and not
expecting you really to have the answer
to this but of those charters that are
participating do they tend to be more
urban than rural or
evenly split rural than urban
that is something that um unfortunately
due to my newness
in the department i don't know that off
the top of my hand but i can find that
information we frequently ask questions
that you you should not know the answer
to off the top of your head so don't
take that as any kind of expectation
so there is no requirement for any
school district to participate in the
national food program
um you mean in order to run a school
yeah that is correct
so they can privatize it they can offer
no
food program whatsoever
yes that is correct
is that yeah
well that was my question ralph can you
speak a little bit about that do you
know anything about how they're how they
they're going about that i don't know
how they're doing it but they decided
that
they weren't gonna because the food that
government said hey this is what you
have to make the lunches you have to
provide we're getting thrown away
that's one of the things we've got to
look at when we say hey this is the food
that i eat well the kids eat it
right that's one of the problems we have
uh so london they're asking what how
they're doing they're offering lunches
right
when we look at the school
and when i was on the school board
in in litchfield what
one of the problems with what was
happening is before they came up with
what you have to
the biggest money maker that the
student-run
shop
had was selling french fries at
lunchtime
because the lunch program wasn't
but then they sort of stopped it because
but that was the students run bring
running they sell other things school
supplies and and whatnot but they were
selling french fries at lunchtime and
that's
what their biggest money maker so the
thing is we've got to be careful of
what we say kids have to eat because
they're not going to eat it
representative woodcock thank you the
purification
on the national school lunch program
site the document you provided i'm just
listening to reverend bowen i'm looking
at page two and i see that the five
or six uh londonderry schools
participate i'm now at least 20 21. does
that mean they have to follow the
regulations of the
okay so
that that information actually a little
dated
perhaps they weren't participating in
the past but
now they are okay but if they
participate now they have to follow the
guy okay thank you
um so the
the next question that i have on here is
um
the participation rate from last year
that school districts use applications
from parents for program eligibility um
and unfortunately since for the last two
years meals have been free um
applications did not need to be
collected for for that um so that's kind
of where the the lack of data for for
that particular thing is
and
we touched upon the breakfast
we did summer programs i feel like there
was one that i was missing
yep i think that we um that we got them
all
i'm very impressed
i i
last week when i asked for questions
from members of our committee i said to
them you know you've got like 10 minutes
to get me these questions because i
don't know how these guys are going to
be able to pull all this information
together in two work days but uh well
done
well done other questions representative
ellison um this is probably maybe to to
uh oliver but you might comment on this
oliver just did a survey and got a
survey on homeschooling which has a
whole lot of comments about i
participate i won't the government can't
touch the food or i really like it the
school drops off
food for my kids once a week
where
what's your sense oliver what the
requirement maybe
what the requirement is around
homeschooling or the opportunity is
around homeschooling for participating
i know no more than you know because
that chart is what i got in response to
my query okay and so we can all
interpret it together which is why i
copied it to everyone uh because i was
flabbergasted i started from the
standpoint of the one thing that was
missing to me as a person who used to do
a lot of research in various things
because no one was talking about
efficacy they were only talking about do
you do it or don't you do it and i
wanted you to know how much difference
it made when students had breakfast
how much me when they had dinner so i
turned to my in-house expert my wife
and she's the former director of state
director of special ed and has a long
history of teaching in those and she
tells me exactly what some of you were
saying the other day
that she took it out of her own pocket
provided food for the students getting
off the bus so they would have enough in
their stomach to be able to study
and she said it's not uncommon and sure
enough in those things you get
tales of people teachers taking money
out of their pocket and buying food for
the students
whether it's a special ed teacher or
just a classroom teacher and so i'm
beginning to think i said
yes there's a felt need
but where's the data on the difference
it makes and i was astounded not to find
any
so i called to
dr aaron sharp at unh
who's the associate dean of health and
human services
and i've asked her for
a study list for us
i've asked her for materials on research
having to do with school meals
and what there is about performance has
anyone done a pre and a post test
on this to say how much difference it
does make
because i thought that part is missing
from the data
and so i was sort of surprised that
nowhere and what you were sent was there
any question like that we're just doing
it because we assume it's better
well yeah if i were hungry i'd assume
that too but
it's nice if you do a study
if you cover your bases
and i think if we had the more data we
have the better case we're going to be
able to build for doing whatever is best
for the students
so that's that's how i got into this
business of doing that
oh madam chair
representative ellison um
back to the homeschooling thing would i
be correct then in in saying that
home school students are eligible or are
participating in
the the food program
based on a local option based on what
local school districts want to do or not
do would that be would i be correct with
that assumption
just to
clarify
um for
during coveted purposes there were some
districts that had the capability to
deliver meals home so i don't want there
to to be a confusion in in that respect
um so there was that capability running
this particular program that
you get into an open site school where
they they have the capability to be able
to to do that um but i'll let melissa
speak to
to the home school part
with regards to homeschool students they
would have the ability to participate
the homeschool students do have the
ability to participate in a lot of
programs so for example you can have an
instance where a student might come in
and take a few classes or they might um
be part of the the team a team or some
sort of uh activity or athletic athletic
activity and so this would qualify under
that like if the parents sought out
that's that resource they they would not
be denied okay thank you
can i ask a follow-up to that melissa so
what if the child is not dually enrolled
if they're a full home school student
but they're eligible they meet the
criteria for free and reduced lunch i
mean i'm not talking coping i'm talking
either pre or postcoded would that
homeschool family be eligible for meals
if the child was fully homeschooled yes
they would be eligible
i just haven't heard of any specific
cases and i could go back and try to
gather some more information i have not
heard of a specific case where
any home school
families are choosing to access the
school meals but i know that they would
still be eligible to receive the meals
okay maybe we'll send you the
information that representative ford
received because it looked like
there were
responses where people were saying yes
i'm taking advantage of it so it'll be
interesting see if it was just as a
result of kovid
how does that play out once the kofi
meals program ends
representative bone yeah also too on
other program this problem a lot of
individual school pro school districts
have different programs with different
things and it's kind of hard to collect
that data one of the good examples is
salem cte which is in salem high school
so it makes it easier
their culinary arts program
creates
bar food boxes for kids on friday to
take home for their weekends
so i mean they're like i said there's
all kinds of different things going
around and it's up to different school
districts and and and they the first
part of it with this how do we know that
having a good people not having good
breakfast don't do good in school and
blah blah blah that's kind of impossible
to
to really look at i mean you ask most
families that say do your kids eat
breakfast most are going to say yes
they don't want to be accused of
not taking care of their kids so those
questions those kind of statistics are
kind of hard to come up with um
i mean when i was in high school i very
seldom ate breakfast i barely sell them
eat breakfast now i mean i don't
my body doesn't like breakfast but i
mean
but i do okay but anyway
but
so it depends and most parents
because i i mean
they're not going to have to know i'm
abusing my kid by not feeding them i
mean that's why the statistic like that
i think would be impossible to get
i just would like to add if it's okay
schools are eligible to use their
mckinney-vento funds mckinney-vento
funds are for
addressing the needs of homeless
students and so they are allowed to
utilize those funds specifically to send
home meal packages for the weekends and
that type of thing so schools can use
it's not
necessarily connected to
food and nutrition but they do
each of the school districts do receive
money for their those students
representative ellison thank you madam
chair uh
i guess a request to someone that i'm
not sure who it goes to at this point
but
i've seen lots and lots of research
about academic success and lack of
nutrition and
i think the committee we need to have
have that i don't know whether that's a
gen question or that's a question here
or it's a question here but i know
that's out there if you um
new hampshire hunger solutions last week
provided us with that information packet
and the last two articles are briefs
that provide copious amounts of research
citations
so um i mean i'm sure we could make a
specific request for follow-up articles
that they think might be germane but
but there certainly is is
a
vote load of
citations in the material that they gave
us
thank you
representative ford
thank you madam chair
partial response to my colleagues uh
comments here
one of the sources you might not think
of for this kind of information because
i admit parents do not want to admit
this
and and i can't blame them uh
but the school nurse is often the person
to whom the children are referred and
they keep records of what they did for
the child and so forth and so it would
be able to infer quite logically i think
from that kind of data that nutrition
and and sustenance
was a cause factor at least or somewhere
a factor in in performance and then you
could correlate that with academic
performance and began to make a a
reasonable assessment that there was a
connection there yeah i would guess that
that's that's done i mean i certainly
remember from my uh
pre-retirement days that
the statistics on feeding kids before
they took exams
was huge that were
they saw
real spikes and improvement when kids
ate before they had to sit and take any
kind of a standardized test yeah so uh
yeah so i would think that that is a is
a valid point representative ford and
that that data is out there
representative woodcock
as well as discipline beyond the
academic piece there's data reflect on
discipline performance by youngsters as
well that eat meals
more to share or any questions for us
we have them
[Music]
i think probably uh we
go on recess as you well know during the
months of july and august so our next
meeting is going to be in september
so you folks are going to have plenty of
time to knock around the things that
we've talked about and i would also ask
my colleagues on the committee again as
i did last week if you have questions or
particular points that you would like to
stress with kelly and melissa if you
want to funnel them through me
so that they're getting them from one
person that would probably be helpful
you notice that i we haven't gotten to
the point yet where we're saying well
what would you recommend
that's coming so so don't go anywhere in
september
all right thank you very much to the
department for uh all of your work
do we have anyone else in the audience
that would like to
speak to anything that they've heard
today yes the american heart association
now it's on right okay
good afternoon i'm
nancy vaughn government relations
director for the american heart
association in new hampshire
we were involved with representative
bernie deshay on coming up with
at least one of the bills that he had
filed 1561.
i do not work at the federal level but
we do have a staff
within the american heart association
that works directly with
the usda and other organizations and and
are very much a stakeholder at the table
around school nutrition standards
so what the representative wanted to do
was put forward a bill to help improve
the nutrition
standards of school meals and we took a
look at how far back it had been since
new hampshire had updated
state-based standards which again were
very much connected with the usda
food standards
and it had been a while it was actually
before the 2012
update to the federal nutrition
standards for schools
back in 2012 it was the healthy
hunger-free kids act that was the
impetus for
the federal nutrition standards
and from that point forward schools were
to follow a set of standards and we
found 99 percent of schools were able to
follow the standards that have been set
there were other standards coming along
for for the the future there was some
other updates around the competitive
foods because they didn't want the
competitive foods
to be competing with the nutrition
standards of the school meal so so that
was elevated as well and and schools
were able to um to meet those as well
starting i think it was back in 2017
um there were some roll backs at the
federal level
so
like the the sodium standards that were
discussed a little bit before there were
standards that were set with the
intention that you wouldn't just have an
immediate um move to what would be the
optimum sodium for for children to be
taking and they wanted to do a stepwise
so there was target one
then target two which hadn't been put
into play yet a target three and then
even a target four which leaves it to um
to
the states to also put together a plan
so this was all built into 1561
but with a little more progressive than
what the federal was putting out for
schools
at the same time you're looking at these
we realized there were many other issues
at play particularly with the covet
epidemic and the fact that there were um
you know products that just weren't
available to schools that had been
before
those supply chain issues so we wanted
to make sure there was some leeway in
that legislation to make sure those
waivers would be allowed for that as
well unfortunately from the writing of
the bill and moving forward things got
worse than get better
and there are the other issues that the
department had just outlined which is
also you know the the staffing and
equipment
there were some grants that were given
to schools to do equipment to really be
able to follow those school nutrition
standards so you know it's not just
setting the standards i believe it's
also looking at the funding for
communities to be able to put this into
play um i really appreciate your you
know looking at this issue not just as
you know should we should we do a study
but looking into what the issues are
across the board we also would support
um you know a farm to school
program where because obviously the main
part of nutrition for for kids and
adults are those fruits and vegetables
that none of us are getting enough of
quite frankly but for children it is
really important that they that they do
there is food security but the american
heart association also is framing it as
nutrition security
and before you know we all leaked i do
have some handouts for you on some of
the information from the american heart
association on all that which you can
look at and if you have questions from
that i'm more than happy to help
fill in
some of some of the
the gaps in in knowledge that we might
have at this point we were also just
talking about studies and you know the
american heart association does a lot of
you know according to studies there is a
connection between what what children
eat not just the amount of food but the
nutritional level of that food and
academic performance i don't happen to
have with me even reference to what
those studies are so i'm glad we have
this summer
to provide you with some more
information because
there is a connection that that's made
but we don't want to just have it be
they say um you you need to have some of
those studies in front of you
we're still very interested in working
with um with
new hampshire as well as my colleagues
in other states on the nutrition
standards for schools what we were
looking at is
the the federal level sets the standards
that states need schools need to follow
if they are part of the
lunch and or breakfast program
what we would love to say because as we
know there are very
slow
movement at the federal level on things
and what we just saw of the rollback of
these standards of the implementation of
these standards
is only going to hurt children and
you know it's really those children who
are the eligible for free and reduced
the low-income um
food security you know marginalized
families that we are very concerned with
as well we also very much support
moving to a healthy school meals for all
it's also referred to as universal
school meals it's what we've just
experienced over the past couple of
years
and the the point of that is is
multiple
reasons why
they parents would not have to fill out
the materials information for the free
and reduced all children would be able
to participate in the school meals
program so it would take away the the
stigma
it would also provide more stable
revenue for school food service programs
which is also you know very very
important as we know um
going forward that there might still con
continue to be some new um some food
supply chain issues um
the people who are out there um ready to
fill jobs at
schools excuse excuse me may or may not
be um you know increasing um at the rate
that we'd like to see
so there's just a lot but we really need
to move in a direction where we are
providing you know as much nutrition to
students as they can
from our standpoint it's a health
standpoint we see children with you know
still have high obesity levels children
who
are showing pre-diabetes if not diabetes
you know
there are so many children
who are taking in far too much sodium in
their diets and you know when we talk
about the taste of foods this is this is
an acquired taste that we all have for
foods that are high in sodium high in
sugar
we may not even know that some of these
foods contain sodium it doesn't taste
salty but it's in there and from the
food industry perspective this is the
cheaper way of of creating food
is using things like um salt products
for preservatives and flavor can i ask
you a question nancy um
am i
understanding this correctly then that
what you were trying to do was to look
at returning the standards to the
pre-2017
level
it's not so much that because those
standards hadn't necessarily
been been
the rollbacks were for the continuation
of the steps to get school nutrition
up to
the par of the dietary guidelines for
health for americans and basically those
scientific standards based around
children and what they what their
nutrient should be um you know the focus
for the bill was really sodium whole
grain um and we also put in sugar which
is not added sugar is not addressed at
the federal level on on school meals so
the reason i was asking that question is
because i just said to kelly and melissa
can you figure out
where in terms of the the standards that
were being proposed by the bill and
where we are now can you figure out
where the where there's a discrepancy
but you may already have the answer and
it really is it's moving on from the
sodium level one to the sodium level two
which in the bill that um representative
duchess had we were looking at that
starting in the school year 23 24.
so
looking now obviously i think it was
february it was announced that the
federal government was going back to
putting in those transitional standards
to get schools given the schools two
years
to get um you know
to the point where they're able to
decrease the sodium in in school foods
and you know make sure that the industry
is able to supply those foods because
now they know they need to
have those available
so great thank you so much
other questions
okay we're good thank you very much
and yes we'll take whatever you have to
hand out to us
this group that likes to read
and and we can supply you with with a
lot more than that so trying to be
cognizant of that not putting too much
on you all at once right so there's more
information in here than you probably
need for school meals but it's all part
of outside the physicians keep somebody
alive we'll take it
um i just have i have one more question
for the d.o.e uh if i if you don't kelly
did you just say no you're not answering
my question i meant to ask you about um
medicaid direct certification
and what you uh
what what you know about what's
happening in other states and
last time around we were talking about
the fact that you know we had looked at
medicaid direct certification and there
were some concerns raised about security
of data and so i'm just wondering where
the department is in all of that
so currently the department really
doesn't um
take us a stance on this it's really up
to the legislature and then we will
follow through with the decision made by
the legislature
currently
right now the federals the federal
government has rolled out the pilot
program to allow those kids that are on
medicaid to qualify
for free and reduced lunch automatically
so we would have the option to apply i
believe the application is due in
september so at this point new hampshire
couldn't participate because there's not
enough time to put together all of the
materials we would need to apply for
that program so it'd be something we
would be looking at for the following
year yeah
but the states that are participating in
that it's because they've gone through
and applied for that program
um and then they're
were approved to participate within that
program
with the federal government our
the data security piece of it when we're
looking at doing we have currently have
an mou with dhhs right now and so
there's no exchange of data that's
happening it's it's they're providing us
information that's done at the local
level as far as the town
and then um perhaps like a student name
and then we're manually going in and
matching that within our own student
information system so we can look at
okay so um melissa white is located in
this town this is a student that is on
medicaid
and then we would match that up to see
that if that is a student that is
you know on that roster and then
therefore that student would
automatically qualify this is how it
would work
so the data exchange piece there's
nothing we are sending to dhhs
it's information that they are providing
to us and then we would not be releasing
that information
out is there already a process for the
exchange of information that's what
you're talking about when you say that
you there's a
memorandum of understanding between dhhs
and doe yes
okay so the process of exchanging
information is already happening to your
knowledge have there been data breaches
or any complication from the exchange
um and this is for
students for snap benefits tanf and i
believe wic
and those are all federally required so
that's why we
do that exchange
excellent thank you i'm so happy i
remembered to ask you the question
i think it was on my list somewhere but
i had so many lists going that i may
have forgotten to send it to you
thank you other questions before the doe
for real goes it goes back to work
all right thanks
thank you
okay so what's the committee got on
their mind
anything
as i mentioned we're obviously recessed
for july and august so i think that we
would be looking at our next meeting
somewhere the week of september 12th
i will have to coordinate that with
our
master scheduler to make sure that we've
got space available and
if any of you have time in september
that you are unavailable if you would
let me know that would be great because
yeah not the 13th no i will not right
i will not ask you to commit on primary
day
but uh yeah in fact it would be it
in all in all uh we we don't have a dumb
primary um
in
all likelihood we won't meet on the 12th
either we'll wait until after the
primary to see uh whether or not people
are still standing so
but uh the farm to table people
have indicated that they would like to
come in and speak
so far to table farm to school i wish it
was farm to table but
i'm not in school anymore so the farm to
school people would
like to come in um oliver i thank you
for uh representative ford i thank you
for that information on homeschoolers i
think we will have some time to digest
it
and then
maybe have some even even some more
questions for the doe when we get back
in september but also when i get a
response from
dean sharp
i will circulate that among the
committee certainly that's a and any
beginning
hit your microphone oliver
she did the work on extending the school
day she was actively involved in that
that whole process which is related to
breakfast
and so she has some background in that
respect is and the the
function of that study and what she got
from it and so
my surmizeal is
that it'll be all tied into this this is
a multi-part
issue and and i think we're going to
have to look at all those parts oh
absolutely if we can just gather enough
information to streamline for ourselves
what we should be studying and what we
need to
study
yes
yes yes
thank you
representative
woodcock your opinion that perhaps this
committee when they've done their
work in the fall are going to
promulgate a
single inclusive bill
no the function of the interim study
committee is to either recommend future
legislation or not recommend future
legislation
but
it would be up to individual
representatives to craft anything that
uh that they were bringing forward that
that wouldn't that's not the function of
this committee okay thank you
and man any regardless of what the
output comes recommend do not recommend
nothing stop anybody from still putting
in a bill right
yep
turn myself off uh on that note then i
am going to adjourn this session of
interim study on 12 29 and wish you all
a healthy and happy summer and we'll see
in september
thank you very much
you